going to go back to dame jones college
who i think can now hear me junk can you
hear me
i can now okay great i listen i'm sorry
it's been such a uh a faffle tonight but
we have you and you're my treasured
guest as you know always so let's start
again i know you've been incredibly
moved by what's happened here tell me
about how you feel about all this
well first of all i'm sitting there
watching the news yesterday with my
daughter katie and we hear suddenly
a message from buckingham palace or the
palace or wherever that the queen's not
well and i said that just does not sound
good so we started watching it and the
more
times that we saw the queen when she was
a little girl when she was a teenager
when she was 21
and said that really wonderful speech
the more upset we got
and when we finally heard the news
at 6 30 uh i just you know i couldn't
stop crying percy was there by then and
even though you expect it
and obviously we've been thinking about
it you really think
she's iconic she's never going to go
she's always going to be there for us
she's part of my whole life i mean i
don't remember not being around when she
was around
yeah it's exactly how i felt that she
carried with her this aura of
invincibility because of the length of
the length of the rain the stoicism the
resilience the strength you just never
imagined that one day we'd wake up and
and she would she'd be gone
but not only that i've noticed all the
things that people have said about her
today you know
how fantastic she was how she put up
with everything but the
nobody has mentioned how glamorous she
was
and her and her incredible dress sense i
mean i know this is probably shallow
but when you think of all the outfits
that she's had to wear i mean it must be
hundreds of thousands of you know tops
that match the skirt that matches the
blouse that matches the coat that
matches the hat with the flowers in it
and and that's quite extraordinary does
she have to fit all those things or is
there a mannequin that um
they put on
i mean because those
but i i've met her oh eight or nine
times and she's always been so warm so
charming so
interested when when i received my dame
hood which was a huge honor i mean to be
made a dame of the british empire or
whatever it is now um i was just
completely knocked out and she was so
sweet and she you know they pin it on uh
they stick it on they have to stick it
on because she doesn't bother with the
pins and um she said oh i'm so happy for
you you you deserve this you've been in
the business for not she didn't say the
business you've been acting for a long
long time now i said yes since i was 16.
and um she was always a delight to be
around and any time that you went
anywhere you knew she was going to go or
be there you would think oh my god i'm
going to see the queen and it was like i
was
a bit like you know
teenage groupie yeah with the queen yeah
but i think everybody was i think you
know president i remember talking to
donald trump about when he met the queen
uh he went down to windsor castle i
interviewed him immediately afterwards
and he was giddy with excitement
he really was like a
fanboy around her
and he was a president of the united
states
i know he did he talked about her all
the time in america how fabulous she was
how kind she was to him and
somebody said it sounds like donald's
got a crush on queen
[Laughter]
yeah but
i don't know anybody and i have a lot of
friends you know who can be you know not
exactly um happy with the monarchy who
and they they can't fault her there's
nothing to fault yes i mean
but but she's not like a saintly kind of
oh i'm so good you know do good she's
fun look at the things she did with
paddington bear i mean that is what
other monarch would do that you know and
she opens the handbag and takes out a a
marmalade sandwich and said i keep mine
in here i mean how delightful is that
she must have made a hundred thousand
pounds you see i think jones you know i
i think you come from a similar sort of
uh mindset to the queen uh in the sense
that i just think
there's a certain breed of woman that's
just tough resilient strong doesn't play
the victim you know dust yourself down
get over
the inevitable highs and lows of life
treat them with equal economics i just
felt like you were you're similar people
in that regard i can imagine you getting
on very well with her because it's i do
think that's gone out of fashion a bit
now it's sort of almost being used the
stiff upper lip is not something to
abuse people about ah
ah yes i i agree with you you know get
up dust yourself out and and get on with
it just get on with it well you know i
was a kid during the war i was there in
the blitz hiding in the bottom of the
various places you know hiding uh on the
bunks hiding in the tube station and
then hiding when i was evacuated and
that's how people were and when i was in
london during the blitz i remember
being there and
my mother was terrified but she wouldn't
show it she would you know keep herself
together my father i think was a little
bit more scared because i think he
understood when doodlebugs come over and
suddenly there's no sound at all and
then they drop it's awful but so what we
used to do
uh me and my pals we used to go out the
next day down great portland street
which is just off malibun
road and pick up the shrapnel and i
would collect it in a cigar box and and
laugh about it and say oh my bit of
shrapnel is bigger than yours
and and we it was sort of the chil the
parents
tried to negate the whole danger of it
and how important joan how important was
it
do you remember what it was like seeing
the royal family staying
in london the queen mother famously went
to the east end and stood in the rubble
buckingham palace got bombed
numerous times but they didn't leave the
city do you remember feeling that that
was a a sort of influential thing on the
country that the royals stood firm
i wasn't old enough i mean i was still
like seven or eight
but i do remember my mother showing me
the front page of the daily mail and
there was the queen and i thanked the
king standing in all the rubble outside
buckingham palace i think it was
buckingham palace i'm not sure but i
remember my mother was a huge monarchy
fan said oh look the queen is so
wonderful and i said well
doesn't she have two little girls
because i remember getting cut out dolls
and she said yes but
they've been taken away yeah and they
were indeed being hidden as you know
somewhere in the countryside nobody knew
and the queen
sorry okay the whole queen would not
yeah all right the queen would not um
would not leave england she would not
leave london no she absolutely said
she's standing here beside everybody and
i mean when i look now
at what happened then i you know i
didn't really i wasn't aware of it i was
too young and i kept on being evacuated
about eight times and then i'd come back
to london because my mother wanted to be
with my father
and it is incredible what the british
people put up with yes with all of those
um yeah and the queen too of course i
mean she was uh driving but i mean when
churchill he could have invade i mean
the nazis could have invaded us you know
it's not because i think in a way you
see in a way i think when i hear you
talk like that i remember the queen if
she talked about it didn't she in her
pandemic speech when this country was on
its knees people were fearful they were
dying in large numbers everyone was
locked down and she went on and she
referenced world war ii and she
referenced that spirit and she actually
invoked the words of bira lynn we will
meet again
and i thought that was so clever of that
as always because she was reminding
people we've been through worse than
this
exactly as you've just been described oh
god yes
a lot a lot worse i
i don't understand
how people don't have that spirit of you
know just get on with it you know you
look my mother had a slogan and i don't
mean this to be uh in any way offensive
but eat all eat all your food the
children are starving in india that kind
of thing yeah and that was the thing
that i had always and um there was just
such a spirit
of family life of wanting to be with
your family as much as possible
and of course i was you know i was very
young and my sister was also like two or
three or four or something
uh what is the queen it was the queen
mother yeah well i met the queen mother
a few times she was an indomitable
spirit too fantastic and of course
she and the queen operated with this
kind of never complain never explain you
know don't be heard often speaking in
public don't give interviews maintain
the the mystique of the monarchy uh and
you see a lot of the younger royals over
the years have forgotten that memo
haven't they and they go jammering on tv
and they they say all they want to say i
don't think it helps with the monarchy
in preserving the mystique
no i think the monarchy has to preserve
the mystique but they have about 25
years ago or 30 years ago i don't know
when the queen allowed cameras
when she was having that picnic
in balmoral and we suddenly saw that
they were real people they weren't just
icons who looked they looked like they
should be in madame tu swords um i
remember at the end of the war
on the day what was it d-day
you said
i know my father
took us in his car
down to buckingham palace and we saw
them all on the balcony and that was
when i first got a feeling i think i was
nine or ten or something like that got a
feeling that
wow this is some family they've stayed
here all during the war and um they look
so nice with the queen mother and her
pearls and her
brother boa or whatever it was and the
young princess was then i think 17 and
she'd been driving a truck during the
war yeah and from then on i i became
quite hooked on the royal family and
when princess elizabeth as she was then
became engaged to the most handsome man
in the world we was then principal
i was so excited that i started keeping
a scrapbook
and of course we didn't have social
media so i would get all those magazines
like picture post and illustrated and
all the uh and and cut out the pictures
and all the excitement about her dress
that was the first beginning i think of
fan
mania of
the um
and she was i mean i i think joan i
think the queen was the biggest star in
the world
yes i did say that in my text oh no i
didn't i think i put that on instagram
she was the bigger who is bigger than
her i mean certainly not any of the
american
jfk i think he was at the time
jack kennedy was an icon who i
absolutely thought was you know
absolutely wonderful and
i was terribly upset when he was shot i
remember driving down park lane
park avenue sorry and i had my newborn
baby i had just been to the doctors with
her and suddenly the taxi driver says oh
my god what's going on and all of the
every single car taxi bus had pulled
over to the sidewalk and people were
standing out smoking cigarettes and
weeping yeah and that's when we found
out that jfk had that but i think a lot
of people
a lot of people have been crying i've
talked to a lot of my friends i know you
saw biggins yesterday
we were
yeah i can't help it it's part of our
life it's like losing your favorite
grandma or
you know i think it is i mean boris
johnson
did you see boris's speech earlier
i did i thought he when he explained how
emotional he'd been feeling and how he'd
actually he'd have to scrap doing a a
pre-planned obituary of the queen
because he didn't want to talk about her
in the past tense he welled up and as he
talked about that i actually really felt
like he captured how a lot of us have
been feeling it's been a very oddly
a very emotional thing
very very emotional i had people calling
from america from los angeles friends of
mine but i thought that charles
prince
sorry king charles looked very
emotional when he was doing his speech i
thought it was excellent yeah my darling
mama i'm so sweet i think he's going to
be a a good kid you've met him you've
met him a number of times charles
what do you make of him joan
i think he's great he has a wonderful
voice really nice voice i think he cares
very much about the community about the
country about every country i mean he
has so many good causes i thought it was
very interesting when he said that he
was going to have to give up a lot of
his charity work and i don't know who
he's going to pass it on to but um of of
course i suppose it's very difficult to
be a prince and the king do you think
he'll be a good king and i saw the queen
oh i do yes i mean he's been rehearsing
enough
and i'm sure
i'm sure that the queen has given him so
many tips about so many things look at
the way he met everybody outside
buckingham palace today he was shaking
hands he was kissing them he was being
kissed on the hand he was kissing girls
on the
chin cheek no not really i mean he
looked like he was uh i think he's going
to be exceptional i think he has studied
it for how long i mean for 70 years
70 years but he's only 72 or something
no i think he's going to be great
remember
joan i've got to leave it there it's
been i can talk to you all night about
this because you just know them all so
well you've had so many great stories
i've got to leave it there though thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us it's a very sad day thank you it's a
sad sound it could be a sad week and i
think the funeral is going to be one of
the biggest events of our entire
lifetime i i really do i think it's
going to be absolutely the world will
descend on on london to pay tribute to
well they all love a woman everybody
loves her loved her yeah great to see
you great to see you thank you so much
thanks bye
you